he's going to play knight c6 and then
you're going to be put you know he was
he was especially b6 this was it he was
about to shove the b-pawn you want to
bet
[Music]
96. i
okay turns out i'm not as much of a
world-leading expert on the kara
nakamura body language as i once thought
i really like uh
this setup because
what is going on that's exactly what i
wanted to say because he's uh he it
allows you to play h6 g5 yes well and
did everyone see the shrug like he like
he just went and brushed his shoulder
off john's like all right i ain't
stressed about it although i'm a little
surprised that you committed to the most
aggressive option
on the board and fabiano he placed this
same g5 move that was hikaru's downfall
yesterday you cannot take then you
simply have to bring your king closer so
before you cannot take a b
a b because a3
no i'm with you i'm just like i'm just
i'm
can i drop an f-bomb i'm flipping bone
blown away by hikaru nakamura in this
game
the moment he played c3 elmira the dude
got up
he spent a total of maybe three minutes
at the board in the last two hours like
he knew it was a draw before stockfish
did
he got himself in this spot and he's
overwhelming the situation all he has to
do is capture the knight
and he maintains the winning advantage
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40. oh
we were worried that he overthought the
advantage oh my goodness
i thought like the king was running away
but now i'm all right we got to look at
it again okay f6 oh your queen gets
trapped look at this no yeah because if
it moves to the age
show me what you're thinking because i
can't follow you
g6
uh rook c7
rook c7
queen h5
king f8 no queen h8 check king e7 queen
takes pawn king e6 and your queen gets
trapped because you go to the h5 rook h8
can we just walk out now and let the
computers play the rest of the game sure
let's explore madrid
oh my gosh you gotta move you lost side
of the clock five seconds move four
seconds and he moved three seconds he
had two seconds when he moved he now has
32 seconds oh
oh my gosh
he's back down now i feel like he might
back down he's down to 10 seconds g5
raja go
aggressive
five don't play king g7 make a move he's
gonna go down g5 with two one second off
the clock oh my gosh
this is unbelievable now how do you
defend the f3 pawn if you're ali i know
what kind of devious tricks this guy's
up to but what kind of devious tricks is
knight c4 sacrificing a knight the pawn
can just simply capture it but the point
is that once this d-pawn captures in
response there is an open d-file the
king id7 is not happy
oh my only report can play such a move
but after his move queen to c1 he is
overlooked three oh my gosh we'll bring
this up we'll bring this up in the
analysis board here that the rook takes
e3 is a shot that dingley red has just
missed and we were talking about it in a
different variation here it still works
we'll show you why rook takes e3 you
have to take otherwise you've given away
a free pawn but after king takes e3 this
king is out in the open so bishop c5
check it's the same exact variation
knight d4 and queen comes to e5 and
white's position falls apart completely
here as if you run your king back thank
you for this one where's your king going
king f1 there's even knight h5 knight g3
we're just talking about that idea in
the other game here's knight h5 here's
knight g3 it's swiss cheese on the
king's side
[Music]
oh well he looked oh he looked shocked
he must have missed something in his
calculations
[Music]
you just you saw the decision made in
that critical moment instead of going
for the draw
and hikara just went there and just
shook his head immediately yeah he shook
his head he's just like oh man this is
this is falling apart
[Applause]
[Music]
beyond the publish he takes oh man he
gives the frowny face i've seen that
frowny face before
that's a yawn who thinks is a his
opponent just blundered big time
danny i know you're watching the show
uh i don't only trust my campaign so
i guess yan is you know he he deserves
it and we don't
[Music]
oh he didn't really also not really
achieving anything is john like singing
to himself
but jan
he pours that tea
he makes a face or two but when all is
said and done and he calculates this
through i think he is going to find a
way to break down white's resources
[Music]
amigos
on another note you used to be uh
streaming quite some do you have plans
to resume
maybe not not today
tomorrow
not tomorrow
right um
have you ever fired a second
why would you ask this
great
thanks a lot jan thank you
i miss luke history and after this
totally lost
and yesterday i'm i win a lost
lost position but today
i lost
the game so
just fair cheers affair
richard i love your jacket
what made you wear it today
i would like to say something you know
overconfident but actually it was my
wife she insisted on me wearing it
yesterday which
proved to be very smart that i avoided
that
because it wouldn't have been fair
towards the jacket
so yeah i chose to do it today
any particular strategy for the next
games
nothing
i will i will think about my outfit
to confuse
that's the winning move thank you
richard richard seems like tradition to
avoid castling is quite popular in your
games recently
yeah i'm not there yet to understand
this tricky move of castles
[Music]
alright thank you so much and good luck
for tomorrow
riding
thanks so much that was a tough game and
see you soon
aim and
[Music]
being able to cope with those few losses
you do
this is incredibly
valuable
[Music]
do you ever look at someone and wonder
what is going on inside their head i can
also trade and take and take and it
takes i take it takes takes takes
queenie two queen h4 g3 knight g3 check
c6 queen b7 knight h1 king there i don't
know what's going on i don't want to
think too much
[Music]
do you want me to give you a diamond
membership for your win
apparently you had three brilliant moves
according to our game review and you
know your analysis and computer's a
little different than our game review we
had three brilliant moves in this game
julia don't get banned again
oh man
i'm gonna tell a story while we have ali
reza here so when ali reza was young
when oliver's was young and nobody knew
who ollie rosa was i think you were 13.
maybe less
[Laughter]
so we knew we knew of this kid before
anyone else did and because he was he
was racking up wins and
he basically reached like the auto band
level on our site we didn't know who he
was he wasn't even you weren't even a gm
yet you were like 11.
okay
and we we banned him we did a manual
review and we said no this is a this is
a human a very strong human but a human
and then i will say this without calling
out any other names one thing that ali
reza you know doesn't know is
before people knew how good ferocious
was going to be i've had more i had more
top grand masters email me about this
account and say this person's cheating
and i would email them you you now have
played and beaten some of them in
tournaments
and i would say no guys relax he's clean
he's just a future star and here he is a
star of the future sitting sitting with
us in the candidates so that's you you
brought it up so there you go
anyway man we are very excited for you
thank you what a game and we hope we do
hope of course to have many more
conversations like this in the future
[Music]
miss amigos
you